It's important to remember that a virus doesn't make active decisions.
It's not as if it creates a strategy within your cells.
Mutations are random errors,...
...but the longer a virus is around, and the more people it infects, the more it will change,...
...and the more those changes accumulate,...
...the more chances the virus has to evolve into something more dangerous.
These four variants, considered "variants of concern" by the World Health Organization,...
...all have mutations on the spike protein.
Delta, the most recent addition to this list, has been referred to as a "double mutant,"...
...because, while it has many different mutations, it has two significant ones we've seen before.
This mutation seems to make the virus more transmissible,...
...and a version of this one, found in two other variants,...
...makes it easier for the virus to reinfect people who have already had COVID-19,...
...meaning these two mutations may have evolved to dodge our natural immune response.
Fortunately, the immune response we get from vaccines...
...is much stronger than our body's natural immune response.
So, while we may see variants that make our vaccines somewhat less effective,...
...most experts think it's unlikely one will emerge that completely evades our vaccines.